[Music]
it is a really interesting moment in
space exploration right now the
technology has just started to get good
enough that we can really start having
reliable and relatively inexpensive
access to the rest of the universe it's
never happened before in all of human
history its opening doors of
possibilities for business for improving
the quality of life around the world by
allowing us to communicate and
understand the world better but also for
us as people to start leaving the world
like we never have before it's a really
interesting moment and and it's only
going to continue to accelerate things
will never be this slow again and be
part of it
become part of that amazing capability
that we've built for ourselves of the
cool stuff that's that just coming down
the pike it's a pretty cool time to be
alive right now especially if you're
interested in exploring the rest of the
universe
the flying in space is a huge amount of
work it's it's decades of work getting
all of the university degrees and life
experience so that NASA will even look
at you when they're selecting astronauts
in the last astronaut selection
18300 people applied for 12 positions so
how do you even get your foot in the
door but if you've done enough things in
your life that you're competent enough
that maybe a little look at you and then
they phone you and say we'd like you to
be an astronaut now suddenly you're
starting a whole new phase of life you
come over this watershed and now there's
probably 10 or 15 years of work ahead of
you to get ready and be competent enough
to be trusted to fly a spaceship and
then someday you get into a rocket and
it takes you above the atmosphere and
the engine shut off and you're there and
you're doing all your work and flying
the rocket and docking with a space
station but at the end of it
what do you do with that experience now
you've you've done all of these
incredibly complex and extremely
dangerous things in order to push back
the edge of human capability and of our
understanding of the world itself but
now what do you do with the the sequence
of things that have turned you into who
you are and the things that have come in
through your eyeball
you've tried to understand and I think
part of the continuing responsibility of
being one of the world's astronauts is
not to keep it to yourself but to try
and let as many people benefit from what
you've done let people see the world
through your eyes try and understand the
ideas behind it through your words so
that hopefully they can go far further
than than you ever did or that I ever
did I fully expect very soon we'll have
people working in a research station on
the moon who will be looking up and
seeing an earth rise and seeing an earth
set and and pushing back the edge of
what is normal for us as a species got
to remember what I was born no one had
ever flown in space I mean spaceflight
is new astronaut didn't exist when I was
born I wasn't a word and yet we've had
people permanently living on the space
station for the last 17 or 18 years so
it's it's moving along pretty quickly
but I want as many people to to
understand it and start thinking about
it in their own lives and so you have to
do the job right
you have to put in those 25 years of
work to be competent enough to go be one
of the folks that's exploring the
universe but I think it's also important
to share it to let other people see it
to the best of your ability whether
you're a poet or a painter or a musician
or a writer or or whatever a teacher try
not to just squander the richness of the
experience and try and find us when he
may many ways as possible to have to
other people maybe see what this might
be like for them so that they can make
different decisions with their lives
[Music]